I was born in Hamilton Ontario Canada
but I grew up mostly in Long Island New
York my ancestral homeland is in Jaipur
Rajasthan India there a lot of academics
in my family my mother is a
mathematician and my grandfather was a
professor of Sanskrit than ancient
Indian history a lot of mathematics I
learned as a child was through what he
taught me about rhythms and sounds good
poetry
I think mathematicians do mathematics
for reasons that are very similar to
those of musicians playing music or any
artist doing their art it's all about
trying to contribute to a certain
understanding of ourselves and of the
world around us one key to solving hard
mathematical problems that people have
been thinking about for many years is to
think about them in a totally different
way one of the most exciting moments of
discovery for me occurred when I was a
graduate student at Princeton those days
I've been thinking about Gauss
composition so a gas composition is a
method by which one can take two
quadratic expressions and two variables
and combined them to produce the third
recites quadratic expression at one
moment to just click does around
midnight when I usually go to sleep that
if I take a Rubik's Cube and I cut off
the top layer and then I put numbers and
the remaining little cubes that that
would lead to a cubic analog of gas
composition
I went on to discover 12 more analogues
of gas composition over the next couple
years but that first one suddenly opened
this door and that door was opened in
part because I was playing with toys a
lot of the work I've done over the past
several years has involved developing
techniques and the geometry of numbers
in order to solve problems about the
number of number fields having a bounded
discriminant or the number of rational
points on random elliptic curves or our
higher genus curves these proofs about
the existence and non-existence of
rational solutions to elliptic curve
equations have in particular now led to
a proof which is joint work with Chris
Skinner and waging that most elliptic
curves satisfied the bridge since
winners in dire condition some of the
most applicable mathematics that's
occurred in history has been discovered
not for the purpose of the application
but because one was just searching for
the most beautiful mathematics out there